à l'assurance maladie merci madame
touraine la parole et à monsieur
dominique borne
monsieur le premier ministre
l'histoire ne retiendra sans doute rien
de ce quinquennat qui s'achève change
peut-être un goût amer de grand gâchis
vous aviez des taux d'intérêt au plus
bas un euro au plus bas un prix du
pétrole au plus bas et vous avez gâché
cette manne avez-vous relancer
l'économie non quatre pays seulement à
300 euros ou plus faible que le nôtre
avez vous réduit notre dette
non elle est ou qui remonte risque de
nous asphyxier les impôts ont ils baissé
non le chômage at il reculé non un
million de chômeurs de plus les
banlieues vives telles mieux non les
collectivités locales ont-elles été
épargné non la grande pauvreté at-elle
reculer dans notre pays
non bien sûr monsieur le premier
ministre vous n'êtes pas seul
responsable de tout mais comme les
responsables successifs comme les
responsables successifs ont déserté le
champ de bataille
il ne reste bientôt que vous voulez au
milieu du gué les électeurs socialistes
viennent de donner congé à monsieur
valls
monsieur macro l'horloger du désastre
l'exécuteur en chef de cette stratégie
mortifère a été le premier à vous trahir
dès qu'il a pu le faire et même votre
général en chef à déposer les armes
avant la fin de la bataille
alors monsieur le premier ministre vous
n'êtes plus que 2 encore debout au
milieu du champ de bataille vous portant
fièrement le drapeau un peu comme le
général lane au pont d'arcole avec le
corps criblé de balles vous et monsieur
hamon intacte frais et dispos monsieur
le premier ministre
l'histoire ne retiendra rien de ce
quinquennat sauf peut-être cette
dernière image où vous le dernier des
fidèles devraient finalement vous
incliner devant celui qui pendant cinq
ans à sa beauté
vos lignes arrières
la parole est à madame myriam el khomri
ministre du travail d'emploi la
formation professionnelle et du dialogue
social qui va répondre au chef de choeur
merci monsieur les résidents ces groupes
les dames et messieurs les députés
monsieur le député dominique dord
vous avez oublié dans vos constats un
élément c'est que l'opposition est aussi
au plus bas un et qu'il ne sert à rien
justement de trouver certains écrans de
fumée moi je voudrais vous répondre et
permettez moi un mot sur la question de
l'économie
nous avons eu trois cent mille créations
d'emplois dans le secteur marchand
sur les sept derniers trimestres comment
pouvez-vous ici dans cet hémicycle nous
dire qu'il n'y a pas de reprise de
l'activité économique
comment pouvez-vous le faire et vous le
savez bien le chômage diminue parce que
justement il ya ces créations d'emplois
et que c'était le préalable
bien évidemment nous avons une chance
dans notre pays c'est bien sûr sa
croissance démographique mais nous le
savons c'est un défi quotidien pour
l'emploi donc justement permettre la
création d'activités dans le secteur
marchand
trois cent mille emplois nous n'avions
pas eu ces scores là depuis 2007 c'était
le préalable pour faire baisser le
chômage
et contrairement à ce que vous dites et
permettez-moi de le dire j'en viens à
regretter jeune gérard cherpion et sa
rigueur dans ses questions à qui je
souhaite bien sûr un prompt
rétablissement
le chômage diminue en 2016 207 ville est
pourquoi nous avons ciblé nos politiques
devant ceux qui en ont le plus besoin et
c'est bien là une différence avec vous
cibler des contrats aidés sur les
personnes en situation de handicap sur
les seniors sur les chômeurs de longue
durée
développer la garantie jeunes développer
la garantie jeunes est essentielle
salué par toutes les expérimentations
par toutes les évaluations nous avons
mis en place le compte personnel
d'activité reconnaître la pénibilité
justement faire que la justice sociale
oui vous soufflez oui en effet il ya un
vrai clivage entre la droite et la
gauche dans notre pays
c'est une évidence également et puis
développer la formation avec vos
collègues de l'opposition certains
présidents de conseils régionaux pour la
rendre beaucoup plus efficace
là ce que nous avons mis en oeuvre nous